when I started my journey and people
started calling me the Dog Whisperer the
only thing I wanted to do is to teach
people there is no such a thing as a bad
dog
safer with me
today I'm still doing what I love but
the pandemic has changed the world
the record high the
SE dog shelters are empty the bad news
is the people
he doesn't listen to me like the problem
is me what do I do more pushes more
problems right this is why he doesn't
listen to you so many things you can fix
already sorry sorry the excitement I
just want you to get fit do you know who
I am together with My Superhero pack our
mission is to Teach the World to honor
the pack code honesty integrity and
loyalty once you get this you're gonna
have everything else and that's how we
create better humans and better dogs one
pack at a time
today
Caesar makes an urgent call to a family
of emergency medical workers who have a
crisis of Their Own
I'm Eric this is my wife Jennifer we're
a family of First Responders I'm a PR
nurse in the middle of a pandemic my
husband is a fireman paramedic and my
son is an EMT we have three dogs Bubba
is our oldest dog he's eight years old
he is a kitty Knicks the Bubba is just
an old guy who just wants to live his
best life on the couch we also have
Angus he's definitely the most spoiled
he loves affection the most so I feel
like he does get away with more than he
should and then we have Bella [ __ ]
let's go come on she's also a pit bull
Bella is our craziest girl she needs to
be controlled every situation she's
always on edge always ready to go any
toy that they have she wants we just
have zero control over Bella it's just a
recipe for disaster
she definitely is a party killer if the
boys are playing around she wants to
immediately intervene
one of the biggest moments we had when
one of our sons was just laughing it
triggered her
he got bit pretty bad we needed stitches
yeah
bella bella bella is dog aggressive so
we're having to watch her with the other
dogs in the neighborhood you get that
point where they're seeing red
and then so she causes anxiety with the
other dogs they get riled up recently
she and all of a sudden attacked Bubba
and he immediately started attacking
Bella back
and bit her through her shoulder and she
actually needed surgery and put drains
in and it was pretty significant injury
um it didn't stop her though because
when we got to the vet she was trying to
attack all the other dogs that were in
there
I am worried that we're not gonna be
able to stop it one day and now I'm
trying to Wrangle 300 pounds worth of
dogs you know they're gonna fight too so
one of them kills each other
[Music]
we're going to respond to the responders
hey hey stop
Hi
how are you
stop that's pretty bad thanks for coming
absolutely
wow that's a bark right there that's a
strong part this family called me for
Bella but they have some brutal dog
fights within this pack I can't just
take Jennifer and Eric's work the Bella
is the problem I have to assess the
entire pack if you don't mind we can go
for a walk okay and the best way to do
that is to see how they walk as a pack
let's go to experience the energy
Bubba come here come on hold Angus
hey
just want to follow you okay and just
you know take me to the few routes okay
seeing them leave the house that's
that was pretty dangerous
super fun walk because they're allowing
the dog to be in front Full Throttle
full force full anxiety full aggression
full excitement all of that the humans
are actually serving like a like a dead
weight so they're not guiding
shoulders up shoulders up
they're walking but they're not in
control
good boy dog should not be in front of
you especially walking in the
neighborhood boy
Bella's pulling really hard she's about
to pull Jennifer out of her shoes so the
first thing we need to do is to get that
dog under control Jennifer bring it over
here
this is like a halter
so at least we're gonna eliminate the
pulling and then once you eliminate the
pulling you can ask for the following
okay
you know all good
come with me Jennifer I'm gonna use you
so she can follow you okay and then I'm
gonna pass it to you when she started
there you go so that way we at least
bring in this speed down
and we can start guiding the car got it
because right now you had a car it was
all over the place it's pulling looking
for dogs make sense so the dog gets
amped
that's all good this is the redirection
this is when she's doing the redirection
when I say redirection I simply mean
redirected aggression
when Bella is over excited by any Target
if she can reach that particular Target
she'll redirect that energy to someone
or something near her so she can't get
to him she has to redirect that energy
you know it happens to a lot of people
when they can't release their energy
somewhere sometimes they will end up
releasing in their own family members
right yeah so it's just small or
something yeah
there you go
[Applause]
she gets really excited and fights a
leash hard right have you ever put a
halter on her no right no she's not used
to it that's a problem you were using
the harness but automatically this
gives you that
see it so this is not a walk no you're
actually nurturing a fighting mentality
and that's not what you're trying to do
right no just honing in on that dog
barking over there by using the harness
when Jennifer pulls that makes the dog
pull harder that puts Bella into
scouting fighting mode
it's not intentional but the hardness
nurtures the fighting mentality which is
now carrying over into their home
sending the wrong signals yeah I
definitely think that Bella would attack
another dog any sort of excitement
whether it's good or bad she redirects
the constantly shows on her nose you see
how the brain changes yeah drastically
that's why tools
are so important to understand
what's the outcome I'm gonna gain by
that tool that is fighting right now
pulling this is calming and paying
attention yeah
what I learned is this the family can
even walk their dogs because of how
excited they all get in the neighborhood
all of the pulling embella's aggressive
lunging means that they don't want to go
out for walks no walks means no exercise
and no exercise for this pack means you
got pent up aggressive dangerous energy
these three are just raw power mixed
with aggression but it's the pent-up
energy that really makes them super
dangerous right now so I need to get
them off the streets and into a place
where they can begin to burn off that
energy and see what kind of dogs they
are underneath
later that day the Calderon family makes
their way to the dog Psychology Center
it's felt like oh man this is like a
ticking time bomb
because these dogs are so powerful and
potentially volatile anything that could
trigger these dogs are locked up safely
this is a first here at the DPC and
we're not taking any chances
too excited as well who's the biggest
problem we still don't know we seem so
over excitement especially with Bella's
redirection the only way we can get a
full picture is after we give this dog
the best workout of their lives Caesar's
first exercise accomplishes two things
drain the dog's dangerous energy
and serve as an example of how to work
out the pack without redirection or
biting
so what we're going to do right now
we're going to have some harnesses and
here we got these big tires what we're
saying is this is where you pull you
don't pull the human oh got it okay
let's get Bubba first he's smart and
he'll show them how it's done this dog's
never exercised and they're known to
attack each other so I'm going to start
slow and introduce the motion to one dog
at a time to prevent an attack we have
to really understand how to harness the
power how to manage the power this guy
he's just going to watch oh yeah okay
Angus should be watching his brother and
sister he is 160 by himself
and his brain he still have no idea how
powerful he is so we want to keep it
that way
there you go okay
good boy good boy
good boy come on yeah
there you go there you go look at
homeboy look at home boy yeah you can
let it go let it go yeah yeah
okay
that's that's the encouragement right
there you see it no redirections no
lounges no problems
oh boy good boy okay now bring him Bella
let's lower that excitement
nope
Bella must prove here now that she's
capable of committing to this exercise
without redirecting again come on Bella
I don't know I'm nervous right now it
seems like super anxious but if we can't
get her to even start the exercise she's
going to remain a threat to this family
oh come on Bella nope
there you go there you go okay good boy
good boy so we're saying this this is
where you pull you don't pull the human
Caesar's teaching a family of First
Responders new techniques to exercise
their powerful dogs together hello Alice
seems slow like unsure but
three-year-old Pitbull Bella is prone to
redirect when excited
they need the dog to focus on burning
energy without attacking her siblings it
was like super anxious why what come on
Bella nope
come on Bella
what
oh look at her go look at her come on
Bella
come on good job but let's do it fine on
her own but that's not good enough what
this family needs is for their dogs to
be able to burn off energy by exercising
like this together good girl come on
she's getting it let's bring them
together
we need to keep a close eye on Bella to
make sure that excitement doesn't go too
high and she doesn't go after her pack
[Music]
there you go
fella
this is all good yeah it is oh my gosh
this was huge for us I mean I can't
believe they're doing so well they
aren't fighting they're all three
together that hasn't happened and it's
been years yes sir yes sir look at that
oh that's synchronicity yes sir
look at this look at this
drain the energy as soon as they wake up
that's your main job so now in this
state we're gonna go for a walk okay
follow me caesar wants to test the dogs
with an introduction to his own pack
using a barrier they first meet the
friendliest dog on the ranch that's
Sophia we rescue her from Puerto Rico
and goes first he's just a big puppy
say gentle
now let's get the old guy Bubba see the
tail he didn't want to hurt her so
that's a good news you know honestly
these two dogs they're not Fighters so
now I want to see how Bella handles
meaning Sophia
is she girly she is growling it's not
good she pulled you to it
sit her down sit her now she's about to
jump on Sofia okay hold on yeah
if they're good tense it's because
you're still tense Doug is telling you
what the energy is your mind might be
thinking one thing but your energy is
completely different okay
so here remember she brought you to
Sofia now we got to bring it to the
fence
because she pulled you to it so I'm
bringing on our terms after everything
we've done to burn the energy and
bringing down the excitement Bella's the
only one who become overly excited so
that's her problem she's over excited
constantly look at the tail the danger
here is that the longer and over excited
dog remains in that elevated State the
more likely she might direct that energy
until someone close to her that could be
another dog or even a person body
language on dogs you can read it through
the eye contact you can read it to the
ears you can read it to a very stiff
tale you know if the Tail's stiff it's
like the equivalent of a rattlesnake
like rattling you know so that means
they're ready to pounce so when people
say my dog is unpredictable there's no
such a thing you know you're just not
seeing it you're just not seeing it for
what it is this is not a Red Zone pack
this is a pack with a red zone dog with
regular exercise and discipline Baba
nangos will find balance but it's Bella
who wants to fight every dog she meets
for now I want to send this family home
with clear directions drain their energy
first practice making Bella sit whenever
she gets triggered we have a lot of work
to do relax your arm there you go slow
down
the calderones head home with new
techniques to keep Bella under control
the next day Caesar prepares to help an
out of control puppy Angelo and his
first time pet parents Angelo my name is
Avery this is my husband Marlon and this
is our puppy Angelo buddy he's like 75
poodle poodles are chill I don't think
so hey June July accident we have had
Angelo for four months he's about six
months now it is just the two of us and
Angelo so he's our baby of the family
we love Angelo but he is an absolute
Terror what are you doing hey stop he
got him at the beginning of the covid-19
pandemic it's just like he finds these
unique opportunities to begin to be the
most disruptive working at home anytime
I get on a zoom call that's when he
picks up his squeaky toys
[Music]
sit stop sit
that's it my very first Zoom meeting
Angelo comes running across with toilet
paper out of the bathroom and I'm trying
to like gather myself and be
professional but also like holy crap
Angela what are you doing
um and even to this day he's a very busy
body he needs a lot of attention it
can't work stop he's biting my chair
he's biting me he wants to play no
and then the minute we leave the house
it's like
come home and we find that things are
destroyed
if we think about the things that Angelo
has destroyed it would be our garbage
can so many shoes that your phone
our previous bed he chewed across that
oh in our budget he destroyed that as
well
hey
it's Weighing on me emotionally as his
owner because I feel like there's no
control I just don't know what to do
come here come here Mr people over there
come here well well well well Cesar nice
to meet you nice to meet you nice to
meet you nice to meet you sorry whoa
whoa he clearly knows who you are yeah
as you can see well thank you I guess
this is unfortunately one of the things
we need help yeah what else you think
you need help he just has not had life
without us so anytime we're not paying
attention to him or we're leaving him
it's like an emotional toll on us so I
feel like
our lack of parenting Angelo
successfully has caused issues between
us of just wanting to be on the same
page but we don't know how right so this
is your first dog right my first dog
first dog well that's great because you
don't you don't have too many bad habits
because a lot of people have three four
or five dogs and they just they have so
much information
what I'm about to tell you is actually
in my humble opinion what every person
in the world should know before they get
a dog okay we are ears eyes nose they
are nose eyes ears so the more you
verbally talk the less you communicate
with the dog
most people go state state no wait
wait come on come on sit sit sit here's
a cookie you see what I mean the
excitement of the sound and the tension
is the energy makes a dog not connect
so that's what that's why I'm gonna help
you achieve the basics of of connection
communication yeah
are you sure you don't do uh human
counseling that's what I'm doing you
ready we're ready we're excited yes
Angelo is an out of control puppy sorry
sorry he's just like a wrecking ball
destroying everything he touches so his
parents are just blowing tons of money
because of it our walks are an apology
to her all right yes I just put a shirt
on here sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry so
I need to bring them to my Ranch to help
them now all right we've seen enough we
got a lot of work to do let's go okay
it's plenty
[Music]
foreign
I want to see how you behave and just
give you a little bit of feedback just
pretend this is your home all right
let's go inside okay
the biggest issue they're having with
Angelo is inside Behavior he follows
them everywhere that some bombs with
toilet paper whining when they're on the
phone I'm getting a lot of calls about
this during the pandemic it can get
really bad if you don't know how to
address it Caesar observes Marlin and
Avery's inside Behavior with Angelo to
see how they interact with no outside
distractions
he'll hear the dog already took over
he's exploring in the environment
my brother had no idea look at now he's
asking him to be on top of an extra okay
hey hey well that's pretty bad
Angelo is sniffing and running around
and I'm letting them explore because I
think that's the right thing to do
there's definitely added pressure
knowing that Caesar's on the outside of
this room watching us they're doing
exactly what what they're not supposed
to be doing too much exploring too much
time on top of them and they never once
sent him to his dog bed
when a dog has no boundaries it can lead
to destructive Behavior especially
during this pandemic when we're locked
up inside our homes together and it can
only get worse when we leave them alone
alright guys you can come out but leave
him inside so we see what he does when
you guys leave
oh
that's it
stay
I'm anxious I feel a little embarrassed
like okay what if this does not work
what if Angelo really is too bad his
brain is is so used to be close to them
and excited so they can make the shift
because we I've definitely had moments
of feeling like I'm just over this this
is not going to change it is what it is
this is our dog it still caused tension
between Marlon and I I think we're
failing
[Music]
want to see how you behave
Avery and Merlin our first time pet
parents to seven month old puppy Angelo
all right let's go inside who has
created chaos in their home during the
covid-19 pandemic guys you can come out
but leave him inside so we see what he
does when you guys leave
okay no
that's it that's it
stay
his brain is is so used to be close to
them and excited so they can make the
shift
so this is this this whole you know
barking stuff is separation anxiety
and his brain he never stopped following
you like the umbilical cord was never
caught
absolutely you see what I mean so that
so his brain was excited so now he's
confused because he can't follow you
but when you were just sitting down
there instead of just telling him to go
to your bed and you guys chill there he
just started doing all of that
so this is a great opportunity for you
to teach what to do
let's do it I am getting a lot of calls
for quarantined dogs with what is known
as separation anxiety left untreated
that separation anxiety leads to an
insecure and fearful dog who looks at
the world like anything could be a
threat and all the Barking the lunging
and the biting follows seen how bad
Angela separation inside he is now I can
teach Marlon in Avery how to fix it
before it becomes aggressive and how you
treat this is to have a ritual so that
leaving the house is the same as coming
home
what I want you to practice is is the
formula of no touch no talk no eye
contact most people say so you want me
to ignore him yeah so it looks like it
but we're not ignoring the dog you're
ignoring the State of Mind the dog is in
yeah people go away when they come back
what they see is a dog they miss them
and what I see is a dog that is excited
and anxious and so the best thing that
dog needs there's no touch you're not
talking eye contact and then reunite
with the dog when the dog has come so
once you go in there there's no touch no
talking to my contact
so that energy you're gonna feel it
you're gonna feel that this human wants
nothing to do with me and I'm so close
to that human
no touch not talking eye contact
so this exercise helps you help a dog to
understand the Detachment it makes me
laugh because I always thought the way
Angela agreed to me was with love but
we're learning that that's disobedient
and disrespectful and we're gonna show
our love in other ways so no touch not
talking to my contact
Tango all the way to the kitchen to the
cabinet to put my purse down to wash my
hands and he just does not get it
no eye contact
so it's amazing having this reuniting
exercise I thought I knew what I was
doing and Caesar has definitely showed
us the right way on how to fix it I'm
going to show you now we're going to add
into this coming back home type of thing
I'm like the pizza guy
now that we're starting to control
Angelo's excitement when we reunite I
want to go to the next level by adding
while we all know dogs can resist food
do me a favor and move towards him
toward him towards him towards go go go
towards let go like put this down no
look
so when you move
in order for him to give you more of
what we're looking for so you come here
and he give you it he'll give you an
obedience Behavior
by every moving toward Angelo she's
beginning to set boundaries he's not
moving away his father
towards him
we we want to give you the position of
leadership while you're moving in yeah
and then he has to give you a move away
from you when Angela learns those
boundaries and sees Avery claim that
space is going to do two things teach
him that creating distance is normal so
leaving the room doesn't result in an
anxiety attack it also means the human
owns the space yes
so the dog can develop territorial
Behavior over food pillows or toys see
how you lower the head right there there
you go
beautiful that's it he's moving away
from you so the way they behave with
food you can say with a baby with
Grandma with whatever you want it's the
same reaction
give a space that's what you're saying
[Music]
I'm into a common environment
by your husband and I can greet Angelo
at the right moment oh
yeah he's done with this exercise he's
like okay I got it
I have given Marlon and Avery the tools
they need but now it's up to them to go
home and do their work
the following morning Caesar begins his
day with a pack hike when he receives an
emergency call from Jennifer Bella's
owner tell me talk to me
and a lady and her dog started walking
and that caught Bella's eye
and she just bolted past me
and I was like
ran after her I'm yelling at her fellow
Village
[Music]
talk to me
Caesar receives an emergency call from
Jennifer a nurse from a family of First
Responders whose aggressive Red Zone pit
bull Bella has attacked a neighborhood
dog
or anything yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
yep I understand listen I'm with you but
uh the mistake is is unfortunately is
where we grow the good thing is nobody's
hurt
yeah it's just a little bit moment of
scare but that's the thing when we have
big dogs whenever they do it it just
magnifies and intensifies and when I
work on this thank you
what's going on with Bella and she's
always overly excited when an overly
excited dog sees something that triggers
them they're often go into one of these
three behaviors fight flight or
avoidance Bella gets stuck in that fight
mode but eventually we need to get her
to the state of calm surrender otherwise
that fight mode could lead to death the
death of another dog or possibly Bella
herself
[Music]
thank you
Bella's dog aggression has escalated to
a critical level
Caesar needs to address this incident
with Bella immediately before her next
attack could result in a fatality Caesar
arrives in Rancho Cucamonga to teach
Jennifer how to control Bella's
aggression when faced with outside
distractions
I think part of me being so emotional
was because I came to a realization at
that that moment like oh my gosh is
Bella too much for us what if someone
comes and takes my dogs because if Bella
were to get out and were to bite a dog I
just don't want anybody to get hurt or
anything like that you were not prepared
for this so I'm glad it happened because
that means to me that this is where we
have to work right you know what I love
today
so what we're going to do is we're going
to release our umbrella the halter set
her up snap her out of it let her know
what we want and that's going to be
their new memory okay okay all right all
right I will get her after Caesar's
encouragement Jennifer is prepared to
discourage Bella's fight mode mindset
relax read step right there
but to ensure Jennifer's success Caesar
must retrain the dog by presenting a new
trigger be right back one with which
she's never had a bad experience
now we're gonna meet Ducks we're gonna
start with them on the back Vella has
only ever fought dogs so it is actually
safer for us to use these ducks because
they're completely new to her and she
doesn't have a bad memory of them like
she does with unfamiliar dogs don't
worry I'll never let anything happen to
my ducks they relax
get used to the sounds the smell the
Scythe this is so good this is nothing
wrong
she's doing great
see her now
she's doing great you're doing great oh
thanks yeah yeah yeah it's a reflection
of you now I'm gonna let them walk back
like that right okay so far she's not
triggering with the fight but we're just
getting started here
bring him over
you see that that's a fight mode
yes there you go
did you fix that one
good yes great yeah he's getting excited
but this was easy to snap out of it and
I said well that's what you want okay
that's what I do come this way we're
gonna take the Ducks for a walk
Caesar will control the dog until he
feels it's safe for Jennifer to take the
leash
I also want you to see when the
surrender kicks in
[Music]
there you go that's surrender
that's beautiful right there
here's the leash to you
it's a very subtle moment when a dog
finally surrenders when you see Bella
stop looking around excitedly when she
finally just settled into a walk and
relaxes I'm not saying she's fixed but
it's a huge deal the Bella let go of her
over excitement and finally surrendered
shoulders up yes
nice shoulders up yes
hey
watch out we got a little one right here
hey the off-leash dog almost flipped
Bella back into a fight mode but this is
where we teach Jennifer how to stay calm
and handle this scenario so if you see a
little dog moving sit down
you stop okay I immediately took a
flashback and I was so like oh my gosh I
this was like my worst fear because air
Focus was on those animals and that
scared me so it's easier to deal with a
dog of leash if you stop that if you
keep moving
so the way they perceive it is you're
flying away if you've passed fast and
then you anticipate and then that
becomes a nightmare when we see enough
leash dog we stay calm we surrender we
stop they sit just like Bella and
Jennifer here she forgot about the Ducks
they're in the bag look they're running
look at them laughs
they're the best ducks in the world man
how does it feel it feels amazing I know
Jennifer has been worried about Bella
attacking again and thinking maybe the
city will take her away but I'm sure
they're both gonna get it right we still
have important work left but we made a
lot of progress today surprise ducks can
cure pit bulls
our last visit um to the DPC Angela's
made some strides but there's been some
some regression down Angelo you got to
lay down the separation anxiety has
definitely worsened
oh my God he's jumping on me and
sometimes he jumps towards areas that
I'd like to keep sick and safe because I
want to have kids later what are you
doing stop stop
and come over stop definitely backtrack
really hoping that Caesar could help us
change that
come on Avery
shoulders up
I'm anxious walking up to Caesar
definitely put a lot of pressure on
myself
um to be honest it's embarrassing as
we're walking in today we don't know if
Angela's gonna completely flip the
script all right so we're here for your
final test I need you a game I honestly
expect him to be terrible
all right so we're here for your final
test I need you a game Avery and Marlin
are back at the DPC with their seven
month old bernadoodle Angelo who shows
over excitement and separation anxiety
do it stop stop
Caesar must help them before it develops
into full-blown aggression her
gonna go in there and practice to leave
home okay so first watch me before they
go inside I want to first show them
exactly how to claim their space
so watch even how I enter okay
the idea is you can't come near me
unless I invite you so I'm gonna start
that way it's not just about calming the
dog when you're leaving home you also
have to let him know you're in control
from the moment you walk through the
door
definitely demanded the space just upon
walking in once they come Angela down
they need to let him know what space in
the apartment is his relax they should
tell him to lay down they come in and
also before they leave right now you
can't follow people if they're calm and
in control of this space Angelo will get
the message
oh my gosh
it's amazing alright guys it's your turn
don't forget keep calm and back each
other up
do it do it do it
go go
sit
stay
go
go as we're working through the exercise
Angelo's just not listening and I can
feel myself getting frustrated go
and I know that that's also not helping
the situation I'm trying to be ahead of
the household like old school terms um
and it's it's not working go go it seems
like you're getting a little frustrated
stay calm stay confident if he follows
you don't say it go anymore just boom
touch
stay
stay
oh Avery back him up
go
hey there we go every there we go good
timing go
I wasn't preparing to take over on but
it really just kind of snapped in the
bouquet this is kind of my moment to
step up to the plate stay perfect
perfect
[Music]
all right so that's the kind of
surrender I'm looking for good job
awesome let's go let's bring him out
let's bring him out I'm proud of them if
they've maintained the exercises and
just understanding how to adjust their
energy work together you're gonna have
the perfect dog
good boy you did it you did it I am
feeling a lot of assurance and
excitement and confidence today so I'm
really excited about uh just the
progress that you've made and that we've
made together I'm definitely feeling
recharged I'm really looking forward to
seeing how we can continue to grow
together and improve Angelo and improve
ourselves and also continue to improve
our family
absolutely
[Laughter]
over the past few weeks Caesar worked
closely with the calderones a family of
First Responders whose Red Zone pit bull
named Bella has attacked multiple dogs
Caesar showed them new ways to drain
excess energy from the dogs and
continues to work with the family on
controlling Bella's aggression
you just turn on the uh the green button
then relax the leash
there you go Jennifer and Eric are
heroes
front lines of the covid-19 pandemic
they're saving lives every day working
14 hour shifts for days at a time they
come home exhausted but they're still
getting straight to work with their dogs
that level of commitment is what
inspires me I am so proud of the changes
I have seen this family make
foreign
ly a month of intense Rehabilitation
Caesar returns to the Calderon family
home to put this pack to one final
challenge
Bella has attacked two dogs
and is at risk of being removed from the
home
[Music]
the price for your final chapter
hi guys how are you good morning I have
a surprise for your final challenge for
the past month Caesar has worked closely
with the calderones a family of First
Responders with a red zone pit bull
named Bella after two attacks
the family may need to surrender Bella
if they can't control her excitement
to work with Vela it was because she
escaped out of the front door to attack
another dog I need to know that we
worked through her dog aggression
to put Bella and Jennifer to a final
test I'm going to have my son Andre walk
a dog by the front door to see if
Jennifer can keep Bella in a calm
surrender State all right Andre
thank you
I could see Bella switching into Attack
Mode her body was getting tense her eyes
were getting fixated on the Husky I just
need to do a proper correction to remind
Jennifer how to keep Bella calm foreign
there you go
this is more calm surrender yeah
very good
that's the one so whatever you did and
whatever that intent dust intensity so
you don't have to like do it three times
this is huge for her she normally would
have been yeah and this is her true
nature her a bigger lucky self that we
all love there you go
this is more calm surrender
Bella and Jennifer are doing great so
far so now I'm going to push their
limits a little and see how they react
when confronted with another dog Andre
yes sir I have my son Andre moving
slowly with the other dog to prevent
Bella from feeling threatened I want to
see how Bella chooses to react to a dog
entering her space calmly
foreign
so now we have to come surrender can you
see it so that's why it's so important
to assess and evaluate how they feel now
what they did what they're doing right
now yeah right
yawning is good a yarn equals relaxation
it means calm surrender Vela has a
trouble pass but you can see that that's
not going to Define her future when I do
Walker I usually put the weighted vest
and her goggles on just to help decrease
I'm so proud of all the work Jennifer
has put in she's even using tools like
weighted vest to burn energy he looks um
they have pink yeah oh my Lord I love it
even more when we put it on her she's
much calmer and goggles that work like
blinders on a horse together it's all
about controlling Bella's excitement
ready showing great success remaining
calm when faced with old triggers Caesar
takes this once Red Zone pitbull for a
final neighborhood walk when I first met
Jennifer she was getting dragged down
the streets by a dog ready to fight
anyone that stepped in their path these
dogs never got exercised because it
wasn't safe to walk them so now I want
to see how Jennifer handles a walk with
all the tools and knowledge she's gained
throughout Valley's Rehabilitation don't
forget distance also look come this way
there you go distance is respect you
were so concerned that we would have to
find Bella a new place to live and then
working with Caesar learning all the
tools and see that she's happy-go-lucky
she's not really responding as much to
other dogs it made me feel better I'm
giving her a second chance it's all
thanks to Caesar
normally she would have already been
barking by now with them she's she's
actually in a super happy-go-lucky
feeling right now so enjoy this part
just like this yeah exactly so let's
focus on those little moments where it's
just awesome I've seen the progress has
actually fueled my fire to keep on
progressing with all the dogs Caesar I
just want to thank you and there's
nothing I could say that would uh repay
what you've done for our family it was
awesome to be a first responder for a
while you definitely were appreciate you
very much you did amazing
Bella Jennifer and Eric have come so far
there's still a lot of work to do but I
know they will improve every day
now they have one less problem to face
while working the front lines of the
covid-19 pandemic this year has been
difficult but the blessing is that so
many people have opened their homes to
dogs in need emptying out shelters
across the country new dog owners
remember this take your dogs for a long
walk every day walk your path with calm
confident love and joy and be part of
something bigger than yourself you can
accomplish anything if you do it
together
thank you
[Music]